on a vu ce bras de fer sur la question
des céréales pendant ce temps-là il y a
toujours des combats on va s'intéresser
notamment à cette question militaire
cette fameuse contre-offensive
ukrainienne où en est-on aujourd'hui
alors on est à peu près à un mois de la
contre-offensive qui était lancée avec
des soldats Ukrainiens qui occupent
toute une partie du front et qui
combattent avec beaucoup j'allais dire
d'ardeur parce que les Russes sont en
face c'est une veulent absolument pas
lâcher quoi qu'il arrive donc on est
vraiment sur un combat qui est un combat
extrêmement dur et qui est un combat
quasiment de tranché on l'a redit on a
rappelé ce qui était 14-18 et on a
expliqué effectivement que on sortait
pour aller se battre pour un mètre et on
est effectivement dans des dans des
combats qui sont extrêmement durs c'est
une contre-offensive qui a eu de
l'armement qui a des hommes on n'en
connaît pas les pertes et c'est vrai que
le chiffre est vraiment très discret
parce que c'est aussi une donnée
importante pour les Ukrainiens mais le
fait de ne pas en connaître non le
nombre est forcément naturellement
inquiétant et ce qu'on sait aujourd'hui
de cette contre-offensive c'est que si
elle reste là et que les Ukrainiens
continuent de la mener pour l'instant
elle a pas encore porté les fruits tel
qu'on imagine il n'y a pas eu en fait
cette conquête territoriale face aux
Russes et on a une vraie résistance
russe rien qui pour l'instant ne fait
que les Ukrainiens aillent en arrière
mais rien qui ne justifie effectivement
une avancée comme on l'avait vu il y a
quelques mois il faut dire que les
défenses Russes se préparent depuis des
mois maintenant à cette offensive et
puis les Russes commencent à préparer
peut-être une contre-offensive que
prépare les Russes du côté de l'Est
notamment à Liman ou encore accroupiante
il réfléchissent en fait à chaque fois
on gain territoriaux et en voyant en
fait comment est-ce qu'ils arrivent à
cisailler quelque part les avancées
ukrainiennes ou comment est-ce qu'il
peut arriver vers ce à se positionner et
on voit là qu'ils ont amassé davantage
d'hommes on parle de 100 000 hommes ce
sont les Ukrainiens qui ont donné cette
terminologie là et donc où effectivement
il essaie de Recon ces morceaux on voit
que au niveau des Russes on est
aujourd'hui sur une capacité
outre effectivement de résistance mais
on a une capacité de réflexion sur le
long terme en fait et certainement aussi
une protection à la fois du matériel à
la fois des hommes ils ont été très
touchés alors des tout premier mois mais
on a aujourd'hui une vraie volonté de
confrontation et de gagner mettre par
mètre quoi qu'il arrive sur les
ukradières et de jouer sur sur l'usure
la guerre elle prend une tournure de
combat incessant sur le flanc est plus
personne ne parle de peine il envisage
pour l'instant c'est certainement ce qui
a de plus triste sur ce qui est en train
de se passer en Ukraine c'est que
finalement on a une connexion avec les
combats dont on est en train de parler
on sait très bien qu'ils sont qu'ils ont
lieu mais on n'a pas profondément la
notion du nombre de morts du nombre de
blessés du nombre de saccages et on ne
se rend pas compte plus de l'impact
effectivement que ça laissera ensuite
sur une population et c'est ça
certainement ce qui a de plus triste
parce que aujourd'hui on est encore dans
un regard soit géopolitique soit un
constat je vais dire de combat jour
après jour et on entend jamais
effectivement ce terme de mots P à un
moment donné alors on voit très bien
quels sont les enjeux on voit très bien
que le président zénitinski quand il est
effectivement défend son pays exprime
qu'il faut qu'il récupère entièrement
son pays lorsqu'on a des bombardements
sur la Crimée on a effectivement un acte
politique parce que vous touchez sur ce
qui est de plus sensible au cœur des
Russes que derrière les Russes rétorque
avec encore plus de violence en allant
frapper alors certes les ports à cause
de la Corse céréalier mais lorsque vous
tapez sur Odessa lorsque vous essayez de
taper sur Kiev vous tapez sur des villes
aussi symboliques et donc on se retrouve
dans une confrontation là qui est encore
au niveau supérieur c'est pas les
combats au corps à corps dans Dombasle
mais c'est au niveau supérieur et au
final on se retrouve effectivement avec
un pays exe